et à présent c'est Bou quand notre cœur
fait Bou elle est pas
louvelle la pendule fait tic tac tic les
oiseaux du lac p p glououou font les et
la jolie cloche
dingou quand notre cœur fait tout avec
Bou et c'est l'amour qui
s'éveille il chanteing BL au rythme de
ce boom bom à
l'oreille tout a Choné deuis hier et la
rue a des yeux qui regardent aux
fenêtres il y a l il y a des mains tendu
sur la mer le soleil va
paraître l'astre du jour fait Bou tout
avec Bou quand notre
[Musique]
cœur le vent dans les bois Laich BO la
baisselle cassé fait fric fric FRAC et
les pieds mouillés font flic flic flac B
boum quand notre cœur c'est Bou tout
avec luou l'oiseau du Bou c'est
l'orageou c'estclaire qu' lui fa boum et
le bond dieu du Bou dans son fauteuil de
nuance car monamour est plus V que
l'éclair plus léger que l' oiseau qu'une
abeille et qu'il fait qui se mett en
colère il en train lesiguill des
merveilles
le monde entier Bou boum qu' notre cœur
fais boum boum
boum boum boum ça fait toujours bou bou
bou
[Musique]